The Disappearance of the British
volunteers Andrew Bagshaw and
Christopher Parry shows just how
dangerous eastern Ukraine is at the
moment
the pair were last seen leaving
chromatosk for solidar at eight o'clock
on Friday morning an area which is
currently the front line of very intense
fighting
following Russia's unsuccessful attacks
on Kiev President Putin's special
military operation appears focused on
securing the donbass and a land bridge
between Russia and Crimea having seized
the luhansk region Russia's military is
now focused on the dometsk or blast
Ukraine's military have proven Brave and
tenacious Defenders and the Russian
Advance had stalled President Putin was
forced to mobilize replacement Personnel
but this risk undermining domestic
support as Russian families saw loved
ones deployed and huge casualties
potentially result
the Wagner mercenary group led by this
man yevgeni priegosim was commissioned
by President Putin to break the deadlock
however this approach has led to huge
Russian casualties and no significant
breakthrough
as a result in the past few days the
Russians appear to have changed tactics
and are now attempting to encircle
bakmut sonidar is 10 kilometers north of
back Moot and according to the defense
sources it has just Fallen to Russian
forces
solidar has some tactical military
significance but is also the gateway to
over 200 kilometers of tunnels
associated with the disused salt mines
and therefore also of Interest business
interest to prigozin in the midst of
this Dynamic battle the two britons were
last seen moving from chromatosk to
solidar
two fighting Aid males moving into one
of the most dangerous areas of the front
line it would be wrong to speculate on
their fate but Sky News understands that
over 6 000 ukrainians have gone missing
in this conflict to date and despite the
good work the britons were conducting
they do seem to have found themselves in
entirely the wrong place at the wrong
time